adrian nell was in mozambique building
an accommodation block with his father
and younger brother
but he was killed on friday as they
tried to make their escape from a hotel
under attack by suspected islamist
insurgents
news of his death reached the rest of
his family in south africa
a day later my son is very traumatized
as is i'm sure my husband but he's being
very strong
and luckily they were able to
bring adrian's body back to camber with
them
so they're just waiting for that
all the paperwork to be done so we can
get them back to south africa
nearly 200 civilians were sheltering
inside the hotel in the town of palmer
after militants surrounded the compound
helicopters could be heard circling
above
but a convoy of cars was deemed the only
route out
in total seven were killed when it was
ambushed and dozens more
in the town itself
the defense and security forces have
regretfully recorded the loss of life of
a group of citizens
who rushed into a column of vehicles
leaving from the amarula hotel
and were ambushed by terrorists we
regret this loss of life
and inform you that we are continuing
our work to eliminate the terrorists
the attack was part of a wider conflict
in the predominantly muslim region of
cabo delgado
palmers in the far north close to gas
projects worth more than
40 billion pounds the group of civilians
both locals and expats were trapped
inside the amarula hotel
those who survived have been taken to
pember further south
but many are still missing including
this woman's brother
you don't know where the person is you
can't reach them in what condition
they're in you know
this is horrible it's destabilizing it's
really not fair
the insurgency in mozambique began in
2017
through a group known as ansar al-sana
more than two and a half thousand people
have died in the fighting
and seven hundred thousand have been
displaced
experts hope the events of this week
will prompt action from authorities
in the short term flooding the area
with government security forces and
providing outposts and patrols on an
ongoing basis
is probably the only immediate response
but there needs to be a think of how
locals can benefit from this
from the economic expansion that is
happening in the area
for now though the only focus of those
caught up in this conflict
is survival iva bennett sky news